at around 4:30 a.m. our satellites
detected a storm approaching the Ares 3
mission site on Mars the storm had
escalated to severe and we had no choice
but to abort the mission
but during the evacuation astronaut Mark
Watney was killed hi I'm Mike Simone
from FX guide.com for wired in a
brilliant return to form Ridley Scott
shows us in the Martian what it would be
like to actually survive alone on Mars
MPC and Framestore provided most of the
visual effects for the film with frame
saw handling most of the Hermes ship and
the weightlessness sequences while MPC
showed us what was happening down on
Mars with the Martian landscape now much
like being stranded on Mars to make this
film while the results are seamless and
magnificent even the smallest task
proved difficult for start it was meant
to be a 13-month project but as the
release date got moved up in fact they
lost 4 weeks and they ended up with only
24 weeks for post-production compare
that to Ridley Scott's Prometheus that
had 34 weeks in post the film was shot
natively in stereo with red camera rigs
and they shot off speed to kind of help
simulate some of the difference of
gravity down on the surface and this
proved to be much harder than it sounds
as the desired framerate wouldn't allow
the red cameras to run in sync so they
had to shoot at 48 frames a second when
they shot Matt Damon in the Jordan or on
the soundstage and then speed it up in
post a speed up Sun sound hard but in
stereo even the smallest optical flow
problem becomes a disaster for stereo of
course with the air being 96% carbon
dioxide all the astronauts wear
spacesuits and are meant to have glass
visors but of course glass visors would
reflect the crew and the lights and the
soundstage so all the helmet visors you
see in the film are actually added in
digitally which meant that for some
shots not only did they have to put the
visors in but do an entire CG build of
the live action just for the correct
reflections oh and shooting in Jordan
provided a great real environment but
again a little more complicated than it
need be because unlike Mars
Matt Damon was working under a rich blue
sky sometimes with white puffy clouds
which meant every sky
I needed to either be replaced or
somehow adjusted luckily the MPC team
invented a new compositing gizmo called
Earth to Mars which is a sort of a cross
I guess between a color corrector and an
advanced huge shift in keyer which when
the MPC team did not have to roto every
single shot oh and while they had one of
the largest green screens in history in
one of the world's largest sound stages
when they were shooting the epic storm
sequence at the beginning of the film
they had to actually turn the green
screen off finally the footage from on
set was beautiful from those twin red
epic dragon cameras shot in 5k natively
stereo unfortunately Ridley and the
editors decided to cut in a lot of GoPro
footage from the astronauts GoPro camera
the ones you see on their shoulders and
so again in a long line of technical
aspects that I guess should have been
easier the footage had to be up
converted from mono h.264 from the tiny
GoPros to match in with the native large
openexr stereo plates that the main unit
shot well thankfully the team at MPC
know how to science the out of VFX
for more behind the scenes action please
subscribe I'm Mike Seymour for Wired
it's space it doesn't cooperate
I guarantee you that at some point
everything's gonna go south on you
and you're gonna say this is it
this is how I am
you